[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing our very
own Lord Voldemort also known as Tom
Riddle now Voldemort has a bit of a
reputation for being well the Dark Lord
and essentially being a direct
representation of all the dis donc and
evil when you think of a powerful dark
witch or wizard he's likely the first
one to come to mind and he really
genuinely doesn't seem to care for
anyone even those that are closest to
him he's intelligent cunning and
manipulative they can make others
believe that by doing his bidding
they are becoming closer to him in
reality Voldemort is on there focused on
one thing and that is power if you are
helping him achieve power then he'll
keep you around if you oppose him he'll
eradicate you and if you aren't involved
with him at all then you are nothing to
him if Voldemort were ever to face a
crossroads we're down one path he could
save a companion and down another he
could more quickly achieve power he
would always choose power even those who
are seemingly closest to him Nagini
Bellatrix would still face this fate I'm
sure if in place of Snape Voldemort had
to kill Bellatrix he would have killed
her just as mercilessly and without
remorse the only reason that he showed
anger when Bellatrix died was because
she had been killed and he was concerned
that he was losing a large number of his
followers Voldemort is also intelligent
and if he knew that disposing of you
could result in him having to deal with
more issues and he may still keep you
around so what we've established is that
he doesn't have much of conscience and
that he's basically incapable of feeling
emotion it's as though he is not
actually able to feel empathy for
another and his focus purely on his own
selfish dark goals at the end of the day
he is always most important in this
video we'll be discussing why it is
is incapable of feeling emotion or at
least certain emotions particularly
happiness and love in fact Voldemort is
infamous for his inability to feel love
and it is love itself that eventually
leads to his downfall let's start at the
very beginning by looking at Voldemort
mother
Merope gaunt Merope gaunt later at Muroc
riddle was a pureblood witch and the
daughter of Marvolo gaunt Moreau grew up
in little Angleton and developed an
obsession the muggle that lived nearby
Tom Riddle senior who was a handsome and
wealthy muggle when myrrh Oaks brother
and father were banished Azkaban she was
in little Hangul Tanvir self this only
fueled my rope to take action on her
obsession with this local muggle man
Miroku
after years of abuse from her brother
and father had very suppressed magical
capabilities however her newly liberated
circumstances allowed her to finally
exorcise some of her magical ability
this magical ability manifested itself
in the form of a love potion that merabh
used on riddle it has been speculated
that perhaps Moreau gave riddle this
love potion in a glass of water
or some other drink shortly after he
drank the potion he became infatuated
with Moreau fast forward just a few
months later the two were marries and
Miroku was pregnant with Tom's child
this child would later go on to become
Lord Voldemort a year after they had
gotten married Tom Riddle was no longer
under the influence of this potion this
occurred by either of the following a
his brainwashing was perpetuated via the
Imperius curse and Miroku decided that
she no longer wanted to live a lie
releasing him from it or be the effects
of the love potion simply were off after
she stopped giving it to him either way
when Tom was no longer bewitched he
certainly wasn't completely happy with
his circumstances I believe that a is
the more likely occurrence as Dumbledore
himself has speculated that Moreau
dropped the curse
hoping that Tom had genuinely fallen in
love with her and even if he didn't love
her that he would stay for their child
as soon as riddle was out of the trance
he went back to the full Hangul ttan
fleeing from a rope and their son he
felt as though he had awoken from a
nightmare after he fled Moreau fell into
a deep depression and stopped using
magic entirely on New Year's Eve in 1926
she went to an orphanage and gave birth
to her son Tom Marvolo riddle Tom for
the boy's father and my fellow former
ropes father baroque died shortly after
riddle was born after years of suffering
from a broken heart
Moreau effectively chose to die as she
had no will to live and because she was
not there to give Tom love and care he
grew up without any concept or notion of
love additionally it has been stated by
JK Rowling that one of the main reasons
that Voldemort can't feel love is
because of the way that he was conceived
because the relationship between his
mother and father wasn't genuine and
because his father was under the
influence of a love potion he was born
with an incapability of fearing love
so in essence Voldemort was doomed from
the start his biggest flaw as a person
is by far the way that he was unable to
feel love it was the fuel for the fire
that set world world off on his path of
villainy I really wonder what type of
man he would have become if he was
simply able to understand the concept of
love he truly was destined for evil and
had no escape and for this reason I
truly take pity on Voldemort even after
all of the horrible things that he's
done and that's it for this video what
do you guys think is this an excuse for
fall don't want to be the way that he is
can he be excused let me know down in
the comment section below until next
time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]